Boris Johnson counting his final days as British
prime minister - in disgrace, but still in
office till his replacement’s chosen.
Why did the Conservative Party accept all
the lying and the U-turns for so long?
My guest this week in London is Sir Malcolm
Rifkind, veteran conservative politician who’s
served as both defense and foreign secretary.
No fan of Boris the politician.
“I never thought he should have been prime
minister in the first place.
He was the wrong person here.”
So what happens now to all the former ministers
and officials who indulged Johnson’s boosterism
and falsehoods?
Will the Tory party clean them out?
How much did Conservatives really do to help
Ukraine prepare for war?
And when all’s said and done, will the next
British prime minister just be more of the
same?
Key questions this week on Conflict Zone.
Sir Malcolm Rifkind, welcome to Conflict Zone.
Thank you.
You wrote the other day that Boris Johnson
trashed or tried to trash many of the conventions
that protect British liberties and the country's
unwritten constitution.
That's a very serious charge.
If it's true, why do you think it took your
party so long to get rid of him?
Well, I think, first of all, I'm not suggesting
he thought of it as trashing all the conventions.
The problem with Boris Johnson is he doesn't
think through the implications of what he
does and sometimes the seriousness of what
he does.
I don't think he's immoral, I think he's amoral.
You're letting him off the hook here.
I'm not letting him off the hook.
I'm simply saying he acted in an incredibly
reckless way because Britain, unlike virtually
every other country in the world, does not
have a written constitution.
For our system to work it relies on what you've
just described as the conventions, whereby
Parliament and ministers accept their responsibilities
and desist from certain kinds of activity.
And he seemed to believe that in his own case,
because he had such a large majority in Parliament,
he could get away with that and he found it
couldn't.
And the party let him get away with it because
the writing had been on the wall for some
time, hadn't it?
Two ethics advisers resigning, one saying
the prime minister put him in an odious position.
The resignation in June of John Penrose, the
government's own anti-corruption tsar, saying
Johnson had committed a fundamental breach
of the ministerial code over ‘partygate’.
At all these junctures, the Conservative Party
looked away.
Why?
Okay, let me- I'm going to answer your question,
but I have to proceed by saying that in my
own case, I never thought he should have been
prime minister in the first place.
He was the wrong person here.
I'd love to have him at a dinner party.
I did not think his remarkable qualities were
suited to being prime minister of any country,
and certainly not United Kingdom, and so did
a large minority of conservatives.
But to come to your question, one thing you
didn't mention was- it is a very short time
since he led the Conservative Party to a huge
majority, far greater than anyone expected.
It’s two and a half years.
Yes, precisely.
But when you when you have such a mandate
and no one -even I - suggest we would have
had that large majority without his leadership
at that time.
He caught the public mood.
He won large numbers of seats in what are
called the red wall area, the northern parts
of England, which have voted Labour for 70
years and suddenly significant numbers voted
Conservative.
And Conservative MPs were returned.
So just because he was a vote winner, you
could look away from all the transgressions
and all the trashing of rights and all that.
All I'm saying is it was inevitably going
to be a gradual disillusionment on the part
of those who had thought he was a great guy
and would make a great prime minister.
But there was a consciousness that removing
a prime minister from office, not at a general
election, but by his own party - the last
time that happened was Theresa May and the
time before that was Margaret Thatcher.
So the Conservative Party does have a tradition,
unlike the Labour Party or other parties in
Britain, of if it comes to a judgment that
a prime minister has become a permanent liability
rather than an asset, it can get rid of that
leader very ruthlessly, as it did on this
occasion.
Well, you say very ruthlessly, I would say-
Well it wasn't very difficult-
They took their time over this.
Perhaps the most damning comment came last
November from Lord Evans, chairman of the
Committee on Standards in Public Life, about
Johnson's attempt to change the disciplinary
procedure for MPs while one of his own was
under investigation.
Evans called it a very damaging moment for
Parliament and for public standards, and he
gave this unprecedented warning.
He said there was a danger that Britain could
slip into being a corrupt country.
Again, the Conservative Party looked away.
Seriously the Tories blind eye has been staggering,
hasn’t it?
You're perfectly entitled to put it in those
terms, but you're using nice, colorful theatrical
language to mask the fact that in a democracy,
an elected prime minister who has had the
confidence not just of Parliament as a whole,
but of his party, it is quite an awkward thing,
to put it mildly, to suddenly dump him in
the in the middle of a parliament.
And that was a gradual process because his
colleagues in Cabinet and it was only the
Cabinet ultimately who had that power to remove
him, obviously were reluctant to act in such
a unilateral way, and it would have been surprising
if they weren't.
So I'm not saying I wouldn't have preferred
it if they'd done what they eventually did
six months earlier or a year earlier.
I personally would have preferred that, but
then I've already told you I would have preferred
him never having been in Downing Street in
the first place.
Isn't the real problem with the Conservative
Party that it has for too long put its own
electoral fortunes above the interests of
the British people?
It allowed the prime minister to continue
doing harm and lying, engaging in what the
eminent historian Peter Hennessy called a
bonfire of the decencies.
Shouldn't the party be hanging its head in
shame that it did this?
Again you're using marvelous, colorful language
and if I was sitting where you’re sitting-
Well Peter Hennessy’s language is-
Yeah, I know-
Pretty much on the button isn’t it?
I was about to say, if I was sitting where
you're sitting, I'm sure I'd be using the
same colorful language, but it actually conceals
as well as illustrates the nature of democratic
politics.
When you have a leader, whether he's a good
one or a bad one, in this case a bad one,
when he's been elected by the proper democratic
processes of the Conservative Party and then
given a thumping mandate by the electorate
- you know, the deposition of Margaret Thatcher,
in totally different circumstances, her integrity
wasn't at question in her case, but she was
deposed by her colleagues and not just to
the party, but the country as a whole was
deeply divided about that.
It did quite a lot- it had to happen.
I was in the cabinet that helped deliver that
at that time.
So I don't regret what we did, but I'm also
conscious of the fact you create a trauma
which can last and can create other problems
by- if there are still large numbers of people
who believe that an unfair thing has happened.
So you can't rush to such a judgment.
It can only happen gradually.
But do remember: compare Johnson with Trump.
Trump lost a national election, refused to
go and organized, or was involved in a riot
at the Capitol.
Johnson, with all his terrible faults, which
I'm not personally intending to try and conceal,
at the end of the day, he went quietly.
There were no riots.
There was no people marching on the House
of Commons to protect him.
He simply overnight said, okay, I'm issuing
a statement saying: “I'm stepping down”.
That's how the system ought to work.
And it did work.
If he leaves office tainted, then the party
is tainted as well.
Clare Foges, former Downing Street advisor,
wrote in May: “The party - Conservative
Party - is a wrecking ball.
It smashes through parliamentary standards
and public trust.
It hurtles through all niceties about the
truth actually mattering.
It crashed through our relationship with Europe.”
She has a point.
Johnson still insists that he can leave with
his head held high, he can’t can he?
Of course he can't.
Truth is, he leaves in utter disgrace.
But the party shares some of that disgrace,
doesn't it?
Well hold on.
I mean, again, you're using wonderful, colorful
language and you're using unqualified superlatives.
What is also true you could have added to
your list of the Conservative Party is that
it has enjoyed the confidence of the British
electorate for 32 of the last 50 years.
Yes, but doesn't now, It doesn't now.
Now.
Well, at this precise moment, I'm not so sure.
I think it possibly doesn't.
But the Labour Party, which is the only credible
alternative government, doesn't inspire that
confidence either.
We're going through such a period.
Britain is very fortunate actually, is what
we don't have is some ultra-right-wing or
left-wing party waiting in the eaves to take
over.
We don't have a Marine Le Pen.
We don't have either fascist or ultra-socialist
sort of alternatives.
So you have a Conservative and a Labour Party
as the two alternative governments.
At this moment in time Keir Starmer is doing
his best.
Let me try and be objective.
He's a huge improvement on Corbyn, Jeremy
Corbyn, who almost destroyed the Labour Party.
But so far as we can tell is the Labour Party
is not at the moment capable of winning an
election by itself and forming a government.
So who knows what would happen.
We're in the process of choosing a new prime
minister.
I want to come on to that.
That's going to be a major consideration.
Yes, I want to come to that.
But what should happen to all those who lied
on Johnson's behalf, the enablers who indulged
him, and some who still do, those who defended
him every time a new scandal broke, went to
the TV studios, toured them, giving out the
latest version of events, only to watch it
crumble and disappear a few hours or a few
days later.
What should happen to these people?
Because they indulged him, didn't they?
Well, part of-
Allow me to-
-people who kept him in power.
Allow me to say, there is no government in
the world, democratic or authoritarian, where
the members of the cabinet accept that the
prime minister or the president, whoever it
may be, it deserves a presumption that he's
telling the truth when he says that some accusation
has been levelled against-
But Johnson has long since trashed that presumption.
No, no, hold on-
On so many occasions.
Because somebody has lied quite often doesn't
mean everything they say must be a lie.
No, but you can't give him the benefit of
the doubt can you?
You can't give him the benefit-
Not if he's a habitual liar, can you?
Well, it depends on the issue.
It depends on the other evidence that is-
You're being very kind-
No, I'm not being kind.
I'm trying to be rational and you are for
once being very irrational, as you perfectly
well know.
What I am saying is that a government, the
government of the country, the Queen's government
has to go on.
You don't just sack prime ministers as if
it's a- particularly those who have just a
couple of years ago won a huge majority from
the electorate in a genuine free election.
It's a serious matter.
And the government, whoever is the government-
I was in Margaret Thatcher's government for
the full period of her term and some of the
time I disagreed strongly with what she was
doing.
If you feel strongly on a particular matter
for which you have the departmental responsibility,
then you resign.
But all the time when the Cabinet reaches
a decision, that decision will be presented
as a unanimous decision of the Cabinet because
those who are in the minority are willing
to go along with it.
So you're telling me that
That’s what happens in any democratic country
at any time and it couldn't happen otherwise.
Otherwise governments would be collapsing
every six months.
But you're telling me now that there's no
need for a clean out of all the old officials?
-I never said that.
Is there a need for a clean out of the party
officials?
Johnson's acolytes?
In order to restore public trust?
You're using nice, neutral phrases like Johnson's
acolytes.
There are some members of his team who are
not my flavor of the month, as it were, who
I hope- whose services I hope will not be
required by the new prime minister.
And I'm not going to name names in this particular
interview because that's not my function.
I'm a private citizen.
I don't see the need to.
But of course I hope the new prime minister,
whoever he or she might be, will use the opportunity.
And actually, the most important thing I think
the new prime minister should do is create
a cabinet of all the talents, because Johnson
didn't do that.
Johnson surrounded himself with some people
he'd surrounded himself with were of cabinet
stature.
Some, frankly, should never have been in the
Cabinet in the first place.
Sir Malcolm, there's a lot of talk about restoring
trust and integrity in government, but already
some in your party are writing almost Pravda
style or the alternative history of the Johnson
era.
The pretense is that he got all the big calls
right.
But he patently didn't, did he?
Firstly, you're asking me to say what I've
already said in public many, many times.
Of course, he got a lot of decisions, in my
view, badly wrong.
Some were right.
Actually, to be fair to him on Ukraine, he
has provided a degree of leadership, of a
very impressive kind that took me by surprise.
And he's been, apart from the United States,
the leading champion of Ukraine and perceived
by the Ukrainians themselves as one of their
closest friends.
But that version is slightly misleading, isn't
it?
The truth is that for seven years following
Russia's invasion of Crimea, Britain refused
to send weapons that Kyiv needed, despite
the fact that they were asking for them on
a regular basis.
Why isn't that acknowledged?
Sorry, if you wish to move on from what you
were previously asking, please acknowledge
that's what you're doing.
You can't blame Johnson for what happened
in the last seven years.
Well, for the time that he was foreign secretary.
He wasn't prime minister, and he didn't control
the government.
And I don't know what internal discussions
took place then.
I know, for example, because it's become public
that Ben Wallace, as defense secretary, was
arguing at an earlier time for more practical
help, military help, to be given to the Ukrainians.
But that wasn't happening, either in Britain
or the United States or in other Western countries.
This is a British phenomenon.
What is true, and it should be acknowledged,
is that before the invasion of Crimea, the
only two Western countries that were giving
serious military help to Ukraine were the
United States and the United Kingdom, and
they were doing so by, for example, military
training — openly, it wasn't secret — some
of it might have been secret, some of it was
quite open.
The British military personnel were training.
How do you think Ukraine was able in six years?
Six years ago, at the time of Crimea's annexation,
Ukraine's army was about 10,000 strong.
When Putin invaded, it was 120,000 strong.
So they not only had to build up an army,
but it was trained in different concepts of
warfare to what the old Soviet Union used
to do and what Russia still does, which is
why in the first few weeks of the invasion
of Ukraine, the Ukrainians were able to hold
on to Kyiv and Putin was humiliated.
Now that was because British and American
military personnel had been actively involved
in giving advice.
You could only give advice, not instructions,
to the Ukrainian military before the invasion
as to how they should operate.
And the second point, if I may, is on cyber.
We all assumed that if there was going to
be a Russian attack on Ukraine, the first
thing they would do in 24 hours would have
been to completely neutralize the whole infrastructure
in Ukraine through hacking and cyberattacks.
They weren't able to do that.
Why?
Because we now know that GCHQ, Britain's special
intelligence agency that deals with these
matters, was authorized by the British government
to give lots of advice to the Ukrainians over
the last few years, as was happening from
others as well, on how to deal with cyberattacks
and protect your infrastructure.
You talk about what was done before Putin
actually decided to invade.
To invade, yes.
But it wasn't until June last year that the
government agreed to help Ukraine rebuild
its Navy, but by then it was too late.
The ships weren't ready for the invasion.
Ukraine's ambassador, Vadym Prystaiko, said:
"We had to scrap the project.
It was just delay after delay."
Doesn't that sadden you?
Well, in my own personal case, I would have
liked more practical help to be given earlier.
That was my public view, and so I'm not going
to pretend otherwise.
But, you know, it's a pretty controversial
question, because Ukraine is not a member
of NATO.
And therefore, the provision of military assistance
to a country that might be involved in a war
in the short- to medium-term is a very complex
question, not just for the United Kingdom.
But they were involved in a war in the east
of the country, a war fueled by Russia, weren't
they.
Yes, of course, of course.
They have been fighting since 2014.
Yes.
But that had become a frozen conflict.
And I was talking about a new war of the kind
that we now have experienced.
So the United States and the United Kingdom
might have responded to Ukraine's needs slower
than the Ukrainians would have liked, but
they responded a damn sight quicker than France
or Germany or any other NATO country or any
other country in the world.
And the Ukrainians have acknowledged that.
Let's talk, if we may, about Boris Johnson's
unusual relations — let's put it that way
— with with Russia and Russians.
In 2018, a month after the Russians used Novichok
to try and kill Sergei Skripal and his daughter
in Salisbury, Johnson flew to Italy, minus
his security detail and his officials, and
attended a party at which he met a former
KGB oligarch, Alexander Lebedev.
No details of those discussions were ever
made public, and it took four years for the
prime minister to actually confirm that the
meeting had taken place.
Is that lack of accountability acceptable
for a British foreign secretary?
No, no.
It's not.
What do you read into that, then?
Well, nothing that I didn't already know.
That Johnson has the long history of being
reckless, of doing things without accepting
the implications of them.
And, of course, as foreign secretary, if he
was going abroad and meeting people of that
kind, the Foreign Office should have been
aware of that — for his own protection,
apart from any other reasons.
So these are all reasons why quite a number
of us never thought he was suitable to be
prime minister in the first place.
Sadly, that was not the view of the majority
of parliamentarians or of the public, who
gave him power at the last general election.
Was he soft on Russia, in your opinion?
Two parliamentary inquiries in 2018 and 2020,
when he was prime minister, called for sanctions
to be imposed on Russian oligarchs.
They were largely ignored.
I wasn't involved in government, so I don't
know the details of what went on at that time.
So I'm not going to offer a judgment on why
that was not done, because I simply don't
know.
Is one of the reasons that he may have gone
soft on Russia, the fact that so much Russian
money was pouring into the Tory party coffers
at the time?
No, insofar as the...
They did get a lot of Russian money.
Well, you talk of Russian money as if it's
coming from the Kremlin, and you know perfectly
well it isn't.
We know perfectly well it's very difficult
to say...
Now hold on.
...where it's coming from.
No, no.
Look, first of all, I'm not going to go into
the detail of this, partly because I don't
know the detail, and partly because I think
you're on pretty tricky ground here.
First of all, the law is you can only accept
political donations from British citizens.
Now, there happen to be a number of people,
not just Russians, but of other nationalities,
who've acquired British citizenship, who are
living law-abiding, so far as we know, lives
in the United Kingdom and some of whom have
donated to the Conservative Party.
You cannot describe that as Russian money,
which to your viewers will sound as if it's
Putin bribing British people, a British political
party.
That's complete rubbish and you know perfectly
well it is.
You were chair of the Intelligence and Security
Committee 2010 to 2015, which gets to ask
questions that the public don't get to ask.
And to get answers.
And to get answers that the public doesn't
hear, either.
Johnson refused multiple efforts by MPs to
investigate whether Russia had interfered
with the Brexit referendum.
The Government said: "a retrospective assessment
of the EU referendum is not necessary."
How could Johnson have known that when he
didn't even ask the security services to find
out?
Sure.
Well, I'd make an additional point to what
you just said.
The Intelligence and Security Committee can,
is free to investigate any subject it wishes.
It does not need the prime minister's permission
to do so.
It needs his permission to publish its report.
Which was long delayed by Johnson.
Yes, that's a separate point.
But the actual report itself and the investigation,
if it was felt by the all-party Intelligence
and Security Committee — I chaired it for
five years and we gave it additional new powers.
Parliament gave it the sort of powers it needed
so that it was not dependent on the prime
minister of the day as to whether it could
make investigations of this kind.
So the presumption of your question is just
not valid.
Let's look at the contest to replace Boris
Johnson.
Three candidates left as we speak.
I know that later on today they're going to
be just two.
All of them were Johnson appointees.
Whoever wins, will it just be more of the
same?
Well, I hope not.
And I have no reason to believe it because
they are very different per-, I do mean, they're
very different from each other.
All three of them are very different from
Johnson.
Sunak, Mordaunt, Truss.
There has no, that I'm aware of, been any
type of public criticism remotely of a kind
that correctly addressed itself to Boris Johnson.
And over the last couple of weeks, if there
was anything new to discovered about them,
then that, I suspect, would have been on the
headlines of every newspaper in Britain.
But there — nothing there was.
We must assume that they have — all three
of them have — a history of public service,
of integrity.
And I'm more in favor of some than others.
But that's, that's a question of personal
preference.
But their integrity has not been a major issue
that I'm aware of.
The two debates so far have revealed very
little, apart from huge animosity between
the various candidates, so much so that the
contestants pulled out of the third debate,
although there will be one between the final
two.
This is a party very much at war with itself,
isn't it?
It's a divided party, isn't it.
No.
Come on, come on.
Seriously divided.
No, no.
Whenever you have, in any democratic party,
an open competition to choose a new leader
who, if you're in government, will become
the prime minister or president, depending
on which country we're talking about, of course,
that's democracy, actually.
You know, if they pretended they agreed with
each other all the time, you'd be saying to
me, ‘they seem a bunch of clones, there's
nothing — you can't tell one from the other,
all saying exactly the same thing.’
That would be your criticism.
Instead, now what we are seeing is a democracy
at work.
And of course within a major political party,
like — not just the Conservative Party,
the same applies to the Labour Party or any
other major party — you have a broad church.
You know, I was not a Thatcherite when I was
in Mrs. Thatcher's cabinet.
There were a number of things I disagreed
with — that's normal.
And you try not to wash your dirty linen in
public, as it were, but if you're actually
standing for office, the public are entitled
to know what are, not just things you share
in common with your colleagues, but what are
the differences?
You'd include the European Research Group
in the, in the "broad church" description.
Of course they are.
They are all Conservatives.
They take the Conservative way.
And their Brexit orthodoxy, that nobody is
allowed to challenge without being set on?
You say "nobody is allowed to challenge without
being set on" — they're as entitled as you
or I am to criticize people they disagree
with.
Well, they get shouted down, don't they?
The big lie is that Brexit is marvelous.
No, hold on.
Isn't it?
I am not a supporter of the European Research
Group because — the people you're referring
to.
But they have exactly the same political right
as any other political animal, any other member
of Parliament, any other member of the public
— dare I say it, even any other journalist
— to condemn views they disapprove of and
to criticize people who are arguing for things
they think would be against the national interest.
What's wrong with that, for crying out loud?
That's what democracy is about.
Has nobody ever told you that.
What's the future for this party?
Democratic?
Democratic, or divided into wings?
You know, hard right, pushing Brexit and getting
rid of all the criticism out there?
Can you think of one thing about Brexit that
has worked well?
Well, I was a remainer, so...
I know.
But I'm asking you, can you think of one thing
about Brexit that has worked well?
What?
Yes.
Well, the country's calmed down.
Really?
Yes.
I'll tell you what exactly...
The country isn't working.
I'm talking about, we're talking about Brexit,
I think.
Yes.
Right.
Now, what I'm saying to you, I don't think
you would challenge, certainly not privately.
You might choose to for the purpose of this
interview, is that for a number of years,
for about ten years, Britain was deeply divided,
including the referendum itself, on whether
— and families were divided and communities
were divided, and there was a lot of aggro
about that.
It's still divided.
Let me finish my answer.
And it was dominating the British political
scene at the expense of almost anything else.
Now, if it could be resolved, it had to be
resolved.
And if it was resolved by a large majority
or whatever majority it was, saying we were
going to stay in, then hopefully it would
have calmed down as well.
But the important thing is that the issue
has gone off the boil.
Mr. Farage, God bless him, has disappeared.
Nobody is remotely interested in him or his
party because the issue itself is not dominating
British politics.
Sir Malcolm Rifkind, we have to disappear,
unfortunately.
Thanks.
Thanks very much indeed for being on.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.